Seymour Hersh author of the price of
power this morning's newspapers are full
of stories about the Kissinger
Commission on Central America meeting
for the first time yesterday what what
chances for success do you give it well
you have to hope of course as any
American would that they come up with
something wonderful I think my
experiences show me that Henry Kissinger
is ultimately a toady and I think he's a
very safe appointment he's going to give
you what you want if Reagan wants a very
tough rattling the sabers of Communists
and geopolitical talk in Central America
he's gonna get it if Reagan wants an out
if he decides politically he needs a
vehicle to get out he could get him he
can get a forward-looking report that
says it's time to disengage it all
depends on what the boss wants whatever
the boss wants Henry will Kissinger will
deliver is the general rule based on my
experience he could surprise us all he
could do something you know honest and
with integrity I don't think it's my
experience it's not very much in him
it's also my experience that his
appointment I think is a message to the
to the to the people of Central America
and Latin America here's the man who
basically in Latin America is viewed as
the guy who brought down a yen they won
again these crime in their eyes his
basic crime was not as political Marxism
or socialism but the fact they viewed us
as being upset about the fact that he
was elected by the people a socialist
was elected he's the man who helped
Nixon bring down our unity and is for
his chief deputy mr. Schlatter Minh was
the deputy chief of mission for the
American Embassy in Chile Santiago in
1970 at the time when we know from the
Senate Intelligence Committee that there
were lets you know from an official
report that there was serious plans to
have a military overthrow so it's a
terrible message to give to people but
it's very hard to read Henry Kissinger
my own private guess is he could even do
something with Castro he may pull a
rabbit out of the Hat anything is
possible
Seymour Hersh was born in Chicago
Illinois in 1937 married has three
children
spent four years researching and writing
the price of power Kissinger in the
White House this book very big thick
book matter-of-fact expensive book
what's this retail 1995 but in the
modern-day world that could have been
more I ended up taking a smaller
Commission on each book to get the price
under $20 because the it priced out a
trillion if anybody cares the price
tight at around twenty to twenty three
dollars which everybody said that's too
expensive for you can't sell serious
books these days so what what crown
books and some of the discount book
stores sell it for 1213 dollars which is
almost a rational price among other
things you currently are writing for
this magazine on a regular basis this is
the August issue of the Atlantic the
pardon Nixon Ford Haig and the transfer
of power
what it what's so far been the most
important impact that you think this
book has had on the political process if
any well certainly I didn't know when I
started I'd end up being an employment
agency for Henry Kissinger I mean that
certainly wasn't the goal and if you
think I'm happy about it you know I'm
not I'm very upset that Reagan would in
the face of a book for all the criticism
with a book it mostly is personal it so
you know the criticism they criticize a
man stood with that I did a hatchet job
whether I'm obsessed with Henry
Kissinger whether I should be spending
my time doing other things and not
nobody's ever gone in and taken a
chapter and open it up and said I'm
wrong or talk to the people I talk with
and get them to acknowledge that I was
misquoting him so it's there's no
question that there's some serious
issues that I've raised in the book and
then for Reagan about morality about
integrity about what the secret policy
was and for Reagan do come back and
reappoint him says an awful lot it's is
it anti-intellectual is it sort of
sticking it or is it the fact that he'll
if Henry Kissinger can sell Richard
Nixon's foreign policy as well as he
obviously did maybe he can sell my and I
think it must be a lot of that he needs
a good salesman I think the most
important thing in the book as I've come
to I've been you know flogging this book
for a couple of months that's been
published in jail and I've been on there
talking on talk shows and doing things
it's I didn't write this but it's
finally coming to me what the way I
should I should have described what they
really tried to do Nixon and Kissinger I
think it was the most serious attempt at
our constitution in our history I think
these two guys were bringing everything
into the White House as we know they
were taking all of the authority away
their real enemies were not the Chinese
of the Russians with whom they could cut
deals but they're Secretary of Defense
you know Mel Laird and their Secretary
of State Bill Rogers and the the goal
was to bring all the power in there we
know Nixon when he was knocked down
because of Watergate was in the process
of setting up his apparatchik sand every
every day every cabinet if you remember
that Fred Malik was running some sort of
a program designed to get a certain kind
of personnel on every in every cabinet
and every executive regulatory agency
etc I think the goal was almost total
control and I think his is his legacy
was going to be his air was going to be
John Connally and I think Nixon's goal
was to go out and have a 40 million
dollar a year law practice and be able
to fix anything for anybody anywhere in
the world well we won't know the whole
story of some of the money manipulations
because I couldn't find it I could find
it but I couldn't write it I mean I was
too jittery about it had a wonderful
book on foreign policy but I learned a
lot the partner story for example is
something I learned in doing interviews
I get up more than 1,000 interviews for
this book and I learned that there was
no way Richard Nixon thought he was ever
going to jail he knew you know what
Jerry Ford was and who Jerry Ford was we
just don't always I mean I hope just to
ask you and I read the Atlantic story
yesterday and I wanted why would
somebody like former President Ford talk
to you when he knows undoubtedly where
you're coming from on this thing why
would he sit down and he gave you an
interview what out in Rancho Mirage or
someplace yeah well I think he initially
did not want to when he was talked into
it by my friends who said you know my
god you've got to see him initially said
he's just gonna I think it was wise for
him to talk to me because at least I'm
right there saying he denies what he
denies we I certainly didn't learn
anything I didn't expect to learn but I
thought it was important I think it's
important for a forum I think they have
an obligation to talk to
like me and escape you know Richard
Nixon certainly wouldn't deign to see me
or doesn't deign to see very many people
he doesn't think her friendly Henry
Kissinger didn't even deign to respond
to requests for interview you know the
other contempt with which my requests
were cheated in a way though it doesn't
help you in the sense of you know you
it's easier for you to say now mr.
Kissinger won't see me he won't talk to
me and there's a confrontation there
that develops well that was she had seen
me because you know he likes to talk you
know he's he's really his own worst
enemy his memoirs were my interviews
that he is these two very fat memoirs
one of the things I allege in this
Atlantic piece is that there was serious
talk about bringing out the 82nd
airborne in the weeks before Nixon
resigned Al Haig was going around
talking about the 82nd airborne and he
mentioned something about one of the
that was a term that Joint Chiefs are
one of the Chiefs over thought he heard
in a discussion they were going to do
that well one of the Chiefs after a
meeting with with Nixon in the December
of 73 walked out of that meeting
convinced that Nixon was giving him the
high sign to do something you know that
he was talking about I'm your last hope
the eastern liberal establishment there
you know I'm gonna juice and he's
they're gonna run us over and it's going
to be the end of end of the program's
you for good conservative tough programs
we're going to be overrun by the left
and he thought he detected a high sign
that may have been in his own mind he
asked Jim Schlesinger was in the
Secretary of Defense and such injured
didn't hear it but Schlesinger later was
among those very alarmed when there was
talk about the 82nd airborne and you
know you know where you find proof of
that it's amazing you find proof of it
in none other than kissinger's memoirs
and he wrote 3,000 pages a lot of people
bought it nobody read it I had the same
feeling about my book you know people
buy it but it's hard to read if you
found anybody s read it cover-to-cover
yeah you know my wife no I don't find
I'm very disappointed in newspaper
reviews and I don't know why I shouldn't
be I've generally treated very favorably
by the press I really have been I have
no complaint
given Kissinger status but they really
don't really I I was press secretary
McCarthy when he ran against Lyndon
Johnson one of McCarthy's lines that
always struck me as very apt funny but
also more apt than people realized he
said the trouble of you reporters is
he said this is your right but you don't
read and we do have that I mean there's
not enough it seems to me thoughtful
stuff that goes on in the media which
makes it possible for a guy like me to
make money and the point I'm making
isn't somewhere in the middle of a
second mind towards the end of kissinger
second volume and when wars i think
years of appeal he describes a meeting
which hague says we're gonna have to
bring out the 82nd airborne to protect
the president and he writes about how we
thought he was upset etcetera etcetera
kissinger told hey whatever you know who
can believe that but I certainly can
believe the first part and it's pretty
amazing stuff somewhere in one of
Kissinger sand kissing in Nixon's
memoirs RN for those who have it at home
page 600 he has a diary entry in the
middle of the Vietnam War and it's a
it's 72 and they're trying to negotiate
a settlement in Vietnam you remember
there was a Christmas bombing there was
all this agony all this angst and he has
hay coming in Kissinger's off
negotiating in Moscow this is in April
and Nixon's mad at Kissinger is he
always was by 72 they were they ended up
being terrible enemies and they still
are although they had lunch the other
day together I mean they hate each other
but you know they're they both developed
into our finest actress I mean they're
both wonderful actors Nixon and
Kissinger they defeat anything we have
that much better than we have in
Hollywood the to consummate actors both
deserve all sorts of Oscars but anyway
that the point of it is on page 600 is a
diary entry Nixon has the styrene he
taped and he transfer didn't transcribe
regularly but eventually got him all
transcribed for his memoirs and the
entry goes on like this there's a issue
at debate up for debate about what
they're going to negotiate with with the
North Vietnamese and Hague comes in and
Hague says he says mr. president know
above all no matter what what happens we
must do something that keeps you in
office oh there it is
you're hardly we rarely see it so
clearly just sitting there like a lump
which is you know when I saw it I want
mana because that by that time I that's
what that's what that's all that's the
whole game sy Hersh author journalist
becoming one of the more loved and hated
of the national journalists does it
bother you when somebody really
unworking it calls us more I guarantee
that don't like people don't like you is
that body do you think that's part of
the game yeah well I mean I did the I
did the meal i stuff I did the meal I'm
a sucker stuff in 70 or 69 when I wrote
about the massacre
of all those them those Vietnamese
civilians and children what bother me
were the calls for about three months
any time a bunch of Special Forces guys
got together at one of the bars down in
Georgia or somewhere and had a few beers
why they got to the payphone I'm
enlisted called me up and tell me okay
they would tell me what they were what
they were gonna do to my private parts
and so after that that didn't get me
nervous as much as it did my wife and no
I I don't like it I don't like I weep
and moan at all the you know I get some
wonderfully nasty review summer right
very funny in fact I just National
Review magazine that bill Buckley's
magazine
Vicco I used to work for Agnew wrote a
terribly funny review I mean
eviscerating me but it was funny you
know gee too bad you don't you know
Seymour Seymour how long how long can
you live in the 60s and 70s you know gee
this guy Nixon he's bad but he's not
Hitler you won't be able to make a
living on the rest of your life we you
know normally look at the morning
newspapers and and we will this morning
however we want you to get ready talk to
Cyrus our four lines from the east are
already lighted without even putting the
numbers on the screen hardly and then
one from the West which means you you're
anxious so we'll go ahead and take a
call and catch up on the newspapers as
we go I might point out that under this
morning's newspapers that the Kissinger
panel story is buried in all of them on
the I'm just surprised personally I just
show you octaves on page three in the
New York Times Kissinger panel meets for
the first time a picture of the
panelists most stories without going
into detail reflect what appears to be
some dissension among the the
Conservatives are upset about Carlos
Diaz Alejandro because they save his
cuban-born he's close to Castro Mike
Barnes congressman from the suburbs of
Washington is critical and saying he's
not going to be you know Buffalo and
this Bob Strauss saying who is a
Democrat most of these are Democrats is
this thing going to blow up and
Kissinger face no he's gonna he's
awfully good at that stuff
I mean this is you know what struck me
about Kissinger when he first was
announced the point was announced he had
a press conference at the State
Department and the bit that really got
everybody's eye that made all the
networks and much of the television
local television coverage I saw was his
call for a moratorium on dissent while a
well he said we must have a time of
quiet he said so he
and we consider the policy these are
serious moments and you know I hate to
say it but the first thing he did when
he became national security adviser to
Nixon was to tell everybody we need six
months for the war in Vietnam the first
thing he wants to do is always cut off
the First Amendment that's that's the
first thing let's just cut this First
Amendment stuff out you guys in the
press let's just have a time of
reflection and when you make that appeal
to a guy like Bob Strauss you're gonna
win you're gonna get it you're gonna get
the national security are you even by
him and he's gonna end up Kissinger's
great skill I think is in his ability to
the staff I noticed is very much his
staff in the post this morning there was
an article describing one of the
consultants is being Winston more the
chairman of the four council
formulations one of his old boys from
the old days and it seems to me that his
great skill if I've done anything I
probably made it riskier for him in
terms of his ability manipulate people
because they might be more sensitive to
the fact that they're manipulated and
that's probably a plus but I urge our
first calls from Boise Idaho this
morning good morning you're on the air
yeah bail I I'm a regular watcher I get
up whether it's just after 7:00 here and
I get up and watch regularly but and
I've tried to call in before I enjoy
your program very much and I get a lot
of my news out of it yeah do you get the
Idaho Statesman in the morning
oh I don't take it okay oh I just wanted
to make a comment I heard Mr Hearst make
a statement I read part of his book
excerpts but not all of it and I just I
just want him to know this it's guys
like him that I think should be shipped
out I agree with you completely
he's either ready loved or gravely
haters and I for one am not at all a
phantom mr. Hirsh in his ill when you
say shipped out what do you mean by that
well I think Havana would be a good
stuff for the first stop but what do you
what do you object to the most uh what
do you object to the most in mr. Hearst
we've lost him well he made his point
Havana Havana what do you say to people
like well I think most people with all
due respect to the gentleman in Idaho
understand I'm not a communist and in
fact I'm quite a very happy capitalist
and this is a great capitalist adventure
I heard you admit that you got a
tremendous advance on this and you've
talked about the money part of it you
make a lot of money off of something
like this you could I haven't yet I mean
but I basically the reason I'm so quick
to talk about it I want everybody to
understand that it's not the total
obsession that a lot of people seem to
think it is you know her she's obsessed
with Kissinger I was very critical of
Kissinger in his policies when I worked
at the New York Times that is I wrote
critical stories about him not even
personally critical I just wrote stories
that put him in a bad light because the
facts put him in a bad light but I I
guess I should say that I didn't want to
do the book particularly until somebody
threw an awful lot of money at me and
said this is a book to do it here's
enough money you know quarter million
dollars leave the New York Times and do
the book and that's how I happen to do
the book I don't know what the Adelle
Castro would make of it but the fact is
that I'm very sorry but you know I'll
tell you my attitude sir again with all
due respects I was much right to be here
as you do buddy and it's my country as
much as yours and I have as much right
to make mar 22 2015 9 war in early days
when I was in the covering the war for
the AP I really began to hate the war I
always thought that I had that that it
was as much my country as it was the
generals and it is and I there's no
reason for anybody to back down and any
point about what you think in this
country Cleveland you're on with sy
Hersh go ahead please yes mr. Hersh the
only thing I can say about your book
because I haven't read it is that I
think the reaction to it is just
hilarious seems to be that the that the
Liberals are the ones that hated so much
so you muscled attacked one of theirs
which is what conservatives have been
saying for years now what I want to talk
to you about is you're speaking for the
platform association you said that
personal integrity is the sin I quote
known in government and then you went on
to say that LBJ would have been our
greatest president if it hadn't been for
Vietnam which to me is just an
incredible thing to say in the face of
Robert Caro's book about LBJ but perhaps
you have a sort of a double standard
here and I'd like you to maybe answer
this for me about John F Kennedy and his
integrity in the light of his bringing
what Mike Royko called Bimbo's into the
White House for his quote back therapy
end quote his ordering the overthrow of
the diem brothers which I think you know
he did and I'd like to know how you
think he did it
and the wiretapping of Martin Luther
King and the involving of the Mafia
perhaps through his and Giancana mutual
paramour to assassinate Fidel Castro
okay a lot on the plate thanks for
calling of course I I didn't say that
about John Kennedy because presidency is
terribly overrated for a lot of reasons
I'll give you some more reasons some of
the words he brought into our national
vocabulary nation and nation building
counterinsurgency Green Berets fortified
Hamlet strategic Hamlet's all of these
words in Vietnam that frankly led to an
awful lot of trouble and I don't believe
for a second that he would have backed
out of Vietnam I think he was committed
to that mistake as much as anybody my
point about Johnson was this that of all
the presidents had seemed to me Johnson
had the closest and was the most my
remark stemmed from a conversation I had
with Claude pepper the congressman from
Florida and so the senior citizen man
who was sitting next to me on the dais
he had it seemed to me the most sense
for poor people and for the downtrodden
Lyndon Johnson I don't know whether it
was we'll wait Carol's Carol's book is
marvelous by the way it makes every
other's biography a joke Carol isn't up
there yet he's only up to the 50s or the
40s with Lyndon Johnson he's not into
the Senate yet even he's got two more
volumes but I do think he had a real
touch Lyndon Johnson in terms of a basic
sort of understanding a
what it felt to be poor and what what
black people and poor white people
really unfair and Hispanics I do believe
that and that's what that's what I was
talking about it there's no way I'm
gonna change that on the foreign policy
stuff he was terrible
what about quick comment on the
accusation about the Kennedy mafia
connection oh well I don't think there's
any question if she's talking about I'm
not sure man but but the the one thing
we do know was that Kennedy's that in
that administration we can't quite get
it to Jack Kennedy but he had to know
about it there was an attempt made
through the Mafia to assassinate Fidel
Castro you seen Sam momochi econo whose
girl was the one one of the bimbos the
microcode talked about that EV up in the
White House one of his girlfriend's that
anyway the point is that Kennedy
certainly was if that's the contact
you're talking about this certainly was
a connection between the CIA the Mafia
your favorite president in the last 20
years our Ike in terms of morality San
Diego good morning hello
you have the Union there you have the
San Diego Union with you this morning
okay go ahead
political Sampson the University of
California in San Diego and it's
somewhere took a class with the
professor canal at UCSD in that class we
basically took Kissinger the White House
here's his first memoir and Seymour
hearses books and did a review with them
and I have basically two questions let
me ask him before he asked the questions
did you what did you think of both books
well
each book by themselves they were very
interesting books did did you reach any
conclusion about Tsai Hersh's book did
you think it was an honest what well
that's part of what as an honest honest
work that's one of the questions because
it's a question that you probably
familiar coming from the New York Times
Book Review digest and yeah it's an
honest book but it's
got a difficulty in that you have a
disposition towards one thesis that
comes out in the end and uses sources
that will basically reiterate that
thesis he talked about a thousand
interviews but one of the jabs at it by
the New York Times was that those are
all people there were political losers
to Kissinger okay that's not review from
those people as far as marriages yeah
what's the question question is where
what interviews substantiated Kissinger
stuff when you have all these interviews
that are basically are negative towards
Kissinger as a journalist do not need
also other evidence to weigh against
that to actually make that credible and
second of all there's a big disparity
events sometimes in the book and
actually what it happens is that it
makes it harder to be able to say yeah
mr. Hirsch is correct about this or yeah
he's wrong about this there's like just
a small event with him you know reading
the two books you have in Kissinger book
just at the very beginning he talks
about his acceptance of National
Security Council of either and it talks
about how Kissinger says he go through a
long ordeal about getting because Nixon
basically didn't like to talk very much
not getting offered the job until later
taking a week but to decide and then
finally deciding and mr. Hurst says that
he actually contacted next campaign to
get the appointment and accepted it
right away and when you see things like
that how do you tell which is correct
okay let me give you a reference go to
the New York Times I think June 11th
it's a Monday it's the it would be the
tenth or eleventh or twelfth I think
June 11th nineteen eighty-three my book
was published most of the initial news
reports was on the fact that I wrote
that Kissinger had approached both
Humphrey and Nixon in 68 looking for a
job sort of hat in hand
academic credentials in hand saying
here's what I can do for you and I also
made a very serious allegation that he
had approached Nixon with information
inside information he had learned as a
consultant to the peace process since in
the Democrat in the Lyndon Johnson
administration although he worked for
Rockefellers a foreign policy adviser
he'd also it's a very bright competent
guy he'd been used by the Johnson
administration as a consultant on
Vietnam and he threw that information
over the Nixon whatever he could learn
about the peace process it was this that
led Kissinger initially one book was
first published in June that denounced
the book as a pack of slime belies the
times then in getting to the question
you just raised who to believe
interviewed the people I interviewed in
the in the first chapter of my book I
called Richard Allen who was in 1968 was
Nixon's foreign policy adviser later
showed up as Reagan's national security
adviser I also had information from
Sevigny Brzezinski although I did not
quote him directly he later did
acknowledge that I had talked to him I'd
also I also had information from some of
the Humphrey aides who described letter
a letter Kissinger had written looking
for a job in 68
Ted meant Ike was his name one at 1/8 in
particular and I talked to other people
The Times interviewed all these people
who stood by their story
Kissinger initially told The Times it
was a pack of lies by the end of the
story he was saying well I don't recall
I don't recall those conversations
Brzezinski in particular did affirm that
Kissinger had approached Pierzynski who
was then working for Humphrey to offer
his services or to help to offer favors
Allen acknowledged that he had as I
wrote I had offered inside information
on the peace talks I don't think there's
much doubt if you go to the I wish more
newspapers would and I'm delighted for
your question as for the question of
talking to losers you're referring to a
comment from Stanley Hoffman who
reviewed the Harvard professor reviewed
the book in the Sunday Times and long
serious review one of the things he also
said is that he ran through some of the
allegations I made about foreign policy
and he said balance he agreed with most
of the assertions I made that I have to
say that but he did raise a couple of
points one of them being that I talked
to the losers well one of the problems
is but somebody like Henry Kissinger
there's always losers there's nothing
but losers when the whole name of the
game is to grab all the power
the people I talked with and quoted are
people who are very prominent many of
them are well-known Mel Laird certainly
nobody can say loser or not that he's a
dishonorable man William Rogers a former
Secretary of State who was a loser
nobody's ever accused them of being a
liar because they're losers doesn't mean
they're necessarily not telling the
truth and it doesn't it also doesn't
mean that I can't verify what they say
one of the people Kenneth rush former
ambassador to the West Germany an old
friend of Richard Nixon it seems to me
if you focus just on terms of Hirsch
talk to losers you're missing something
which is that I've been in this town for
25 years I know a loser from a winner
and I understand that losers because
they're losers often know a great deal
and are more willing to talk it's my
function to verify what they say price
of power Kissinger in the Nixon White
House Austin Texas go ahead please Iran
with sy Hersh all right hi I'm here no
no go ahead please
well basically I just had the two
comments to make I have not read few
more verses book but about in a
Nicaraguan I think basically what I
wanted to say is that for all the
oppression that we hear on the media how
the ledges government there is is very
oppressive towards those people I think
is the main point that I would like to
make is visit the far left has no
equivalent of the right wing desk laws
and secondly the second point I would
like to make is for any solution to the
Salvadoran conflict there has to be a
political power sharing sort of
arrangement to begin to control the
far-right structure of government that
we have in El Salvador today and one one
last comment that I would like to make
is that the Ronald Reagan presidency is
a somewhat I'm able to pick up from your
discussion there seems to be some
similarities in the for control of power
that I find very very scary
and okay thanks I want to ask a
follow-up to that gentleman's call the
Reagan administration is an honest in
the press operation in particular we're
getting honest information this
morning's paper has a story where the
president disagrees with his army chief
of staff general Wickham and said that
we weren't ready around the world and
military affairs Laurie speaks as quoted
saying the president disagrees with that
what is that is that what I think simple
thing I think the Reagan administration
is not the Nixon administration Ronald
Reagan is not as defective as Nixon he's
not as bright also and doesn't know as
much and there is something to be said
in in what was very scary about Nixon
and Kissinger was how much they knew how
bright they were how crooked they were
really that was people aren't no no
they're very deceiving
yeah but they're normally conniving
they're not they're not super winners
like Nixon and Kissinger was Nikola
mahir's Nixon has been down and out for
how long you know would you buy a used
car from this guy has been asked for 20
for 30 years now and we still gave him
60% in 1972 what a wonderful job he did
if anybody had known the truth about
Nixon and 72 in terms of the games he
played with Kissinger wiretapping the
secret bombing of Cambodia the
activities against Ellsberg the yen they
stopped the domestic spying what
would've been elected but he managed to
put a lid on it to get to your question
his witness is the most ignorant gun
we've ever had I think I know we've
probably had some amazingly ignorant
governments this is just a government
that really we have a a presidency
really the president simply is not on
top of issues and the tragedy is we are
in operation in Central America in which
intelligence isn't playing much of a
role because it's all being manipulated
in which the president has made up his
mind about what he wants to do it and
that's what's gonna happen and it's very
sad Oklahoma City you're on with sy
Hersh go ahead please been looking at
she's been for 26 months now I've
attempted to get him previously but I
just wanted to commend you and
the staff for the fine job you're doing
your coverage of of journalism is such
that it does provide an outlet that most
of the channels do not have especially
the call-in shows let me interrupt to
ask you a question because one of the
things we talk about here is journalism
with sy Hersh and he's been at the
forefront of it what have you what what
is your your feeling about journalists
if you've watched for 26 months you've
met more journalists than anybody else
well I'm a member of the Sam Donaldson
school that is to say I almost consider
the the world of journalism to be the
forth arm of government that seems
awfully far out to many people he
doesn't to me they did a good job I am
interested in writing I've done little
freelancing but to me it's become a at
this point in my life I'm not young
anymore but I've just become interested
in and seeing that the truth is
presented at least as I perceive it
better in a couple Wars I was down in
Nam when the French were getting booted
up I never thought that would happen and
it did and whereas Ronald Reagan had a
change from the liberal to the right
late life I have had the in hit the the
effect of the last 2025 years is that
just about the opposite effect upon me
how about a question for mr. Hurst
uh for mr. Hearst the only thing I can
say is that I admire I haven't read it
the price of power
I read him one he's in Atlantica
that's another thing that the current
administration is created for me it I
start reading more and I've enjoyed his
things in the Atlantic I think he's a
superb writer I would only hope that in
his wanderings and contacts Ron
Washington he can do much the same for
the current administration that he has
done for mr. Kissinger all right sir
thank you for the call on the call from
San Diego triggers a question for you
they use it in schools when you're
writing these things what do you want I
mean you work for gene McCarthy
obviously have a political gut reaction
to the world do you want the book to
have a political reaction or do you want
it to have a historical reaction or when
you're writing a book like they're
spending four years what's it all about
why are you doing it you want to sell
books okay that's one thing you want to
do I mean you have to say that first you
want to write a book that's gonna it
doesn't mean you change anything this
book could work because if done right
the analogy was I was standing on you
know I'm standing on a diving board
jumping into a pool I know I'm gonna get
wet and I didn't know how bad it was
when I signed the contract but I knew if
I did this book right I would find
things because Richard Nixon is a man of
endless fascination for the United
States I didn't have any grandiose ideas
I really didn't think in I was just too
busy scrambling I didn't I I didn't
think it's gonna be a book used in
campuses a lot and I frankly I'm
delighted I mean I can tell my publisher
tells me that the universities call up
with orders you know reluctantly because
they don't like to order hardback books
but clearly it's going to be used in an
awful lot of campuses and I'm getting
incredible mail I'm getting a lot of
mail I mean so much mail I don't I get
nervous about being not being able to
answer to all
and it's rational mail I mean people
disagree with me so clearly it's going
to have an effect on colleges and I
hadn't thought about that I had thought
you tell the story about this guy and
he's out there forever
I mean you know he's out of power to
keep him out of power and let's just try
and improve I guess in my Pollyanna way
if he asked me what I thought I'm a good
old-fashioned Liberal Democrat but you
know something one of the things I
learned covering the Pentagon in the
middle 60s is forget that business of of
left and right you know I said in the
speech that was shown whether it was all
shown or not I remember saying it's not
whether you're a liberal or a Democrat
or a Republican or a conservative or a
left-wing or right-wing words whether
they have personal integrity that
matters and my story's clearly all the
stories I read about the CIA and about
military stuff I know a lot of military
people I know a lot of people in the
intelligence community whose political
views and personal views I some of the
guys in the Pentagon who I used to deal
with we couldn't agree on a social issue
if we stood on our heads I mean some of
them were very racist some of the senior
Navy officers for example of West Point
southern boys but damn it they had an
incredible amount of integrity and they
couldn't stand what was going on the
line they were doing in Vietnam and it
would come to me because at least they
saw me as somebody that didn't betray a
confidence and whatever my personal
views are at least they knew where I was
I wasn't playing any games I'm a you
know I'm a liberal Democrat I mean I I
couldn't vote for Richard Nixon if I
stood on my head I don't think that's
the issue I'm still a professional
journalist and we know we as journalists
have to understand that we're entitle
have some rights and we and we can't
walk around saying we don't have no
politics we all do and it doesn't that
doesn't seem to matter very much what
matters is what we write and you know as
I said earlier somebody wants to
criticize me by opening up a chapter and
quoting people and saying they were
misquoted or showing how I was wrong or
showing as that fellow in San Diego said
that the people I used the role terribly
biased and dishonest sources who were
losers in a bureaucracy and a
bureaucratic struggle I think if
somebody would do that I just take off
my hat and bow but that's what needs to
be done it seems to me rather than go
around and talk about what my motives
were because what difference does it
make I'm a professional
so Hearst we go to Miami good morning
I don't know tomlinson about money
Florida yet I think he is good mr. Hirsh
if he ever picked up on any kind of the
unofficial Red Hawk concern amongst
congressmen and the potential for
radical be radical moves by Nixon and
his people to seize power you know
during the winding days of his uh his
administration by that I mean you know
was there any contingency plan being
developed by congressmen they had such a
move off well I'm gonna sell a copy of
my magazine the Atlantic to you because
if you read it in the middle of it
there's a long discussion of just what
you're saying there was a concern not by
congressman but by the Secretary of
Defense mr. Jim Schlesinger that
something was afoot in the White House
and that basically he did a study of the
82nd airborne and what forces would be
available and his concern was to be
perfectly honest was that the Marines
who were very dominant in Washington
just in terms of the physical presence
there's a barracks here in Southeast
Washington there's the Quantico training
station about 30 40 miles away his
concern was that in the Marines if Nixon
asked him to do something might stay
loyal even if he asked him to do
something extra legal on grounds that
the Commandant of the Marines
general Cushman had been a personal aide
to Richard Nixon when Nixon was vice
president and it's a pretty scary story
and there I go I'm selling a magazine I
don't I don't think I think if you're
interested you can get in touch with me
through the Atlantic all they forward
everything to me promptly by the way I
point out that gentlemen we've been
anxious to have on the program will be
here Monday Philip Taubman from the New
York Times the reason is that often on
Monday morning when the weekends are
slow mr. Talman has a major foreign
policy story on the front page of the
New York Times it finds its way on the
front pages of almost all the New York
Times News Service papers around the
country and we want to defend some very
good stuff on Central America let's go
to Jacksonville Florida next for sy
Hersh good morning mr. Hirsh um I just
wanted to ask you a question in the past
10 or 12 years events and investigations
have revealed a pattern of
hiring of ex CIA agents and consultants
by the political campaigns government
agencies and corporations one that his
most obvious is McCord and associates
who were security consultants for the
committee to re-elect the president
Richard Nixon and more recently the
Reagan campaign
Casey and his network of retired CIA
agent and the briefing book scandal
would you care to comment on what this
practice is doing to the American system
and would you possibly write an article
about it well actually I did in 71 I
took a break from my book and I wrote a
long series of articles for the New York
Times magazine on the Qaddafi connection
this the two CIA agents Ed Wilson and
two frank terpil who'd gone to work for
Gaddafi Muammar Gaddafi of Libya and
were training terrorists I guess
training PLO operatives in how to use
bombs etc the information they learn and
skills they learn while in the CIA all
at hyphy I would add to your concern or
to your general question by saying also
the number of CIA agents that now work
for foreign governments is a little
frightening many former retired CIA
officials are served for example there's
a fellow in very closed who was the
station chief in Saudi Arabia who
retired after a long and successful
career in the CIA was a very highly
skilled man apparently and who became
then hired on to the Saudi government in
charge of as a consultant to internal
security or a foreign security for their
just general security for the Saudi
government well that sort of
prostitution it seems to me you know and
one of the things you see in foreign
many foreign countries openly advertised
for retired national security agency
officials men who monitor communications
intelligence to go to work and their
communications facilities overseas so we
have a very very serious erosion of not
only men not only technology but also
manpower and it does raise questions and
the briefing gate or the stories
disappeared but I I suggest to you that
it's too bad it did because I think
there probably was more to it New York
City good morning come on
first thing I'd like to graduate mr.
Parrish on his book there because I do
have the book and I do find it very
interesting let me address a lot of my
suspicions in the past so let me ask you
a couple questions have you read the
book in its entirety no all right I got
it
two weeks ago and I'm going through it's
very slow and very carefully and I'm not
missing anything in between do you
normally read a book this size from
cover to cover
no one of the alarms so far well I
learned a lot that my thing is that I
think a lot of this was set up back in
the Eisenhower Nixon era and it followed
right on through run-up to the present
and it's still going on today with the
Reagan Carter and administration as well
as the Ford administration he's say
going on what is it that's going on well
I find that for instance an article
appeared in New York news yesterday on
page seven or eight which Nixon
Kissinger confirmed one another and a
hotel in New York a secret meeting about
the policy on South America and I find
that it has been no deviation because
Kissinger had his hand in the
[Music]
administration's all the way around the
clock from Eisenhower right on up to the
present and like there's a lot of dirty
tricks being pulled and the public
doesn't know about it and the most
important fact is that Rockefeller
refused the presidency a vice presidency
under Nixon but he accepted a loan to
Ford and everybody knows that
Rockefeller wanted to become president
the United States and here's something
hidden behind there another fact that I
find very interesting that Nixon told
Ford who shot Kennedy and did you find
that that was on the television at that
time there when the news media brought
it out with the transition of power at
when Ford was being elected to being
nominated for a president's and there's
a lot of small little things that add up
but I find that we're being set up for
another Vietnam crisis but it doesn't
indicate what part of the
whether it be South America or South
Africa but we are being set up okay
thanks for the call
let me ask you about that meeting in New
York it's yeah I don't think it would
could have been secret had pictures in
the paper yesterday the kissing
Nixon lunch at a French restaurant up
there why would mr. Kissinger do
something like this at this point nine
years after he's moving he's once again
trying to I'm guessing that's my
speculation that's maybe a shade
one-millimeter better than anybody
else's I really don't know let's start
off by saying I don't know my guess is
he's touching all the all the right
points the tickets that punching the
tickets to for the right you know it was
Nixon still held in a great deal of with
a great deal of respect by many people
on the reagan camp he still talks to the
president there's still some conferring
oh that goes on and I think it's just a
to show that he's gonna be a good boy
he's you mentioned that you did a lot of
work on the in the terpil situation
Wilson over in the Qadhafi regime the
Chad thing is all over the front page
that's not to worry about
oh yeah it's terrifyingly stupid to go
jump into the middle of a crazy
long-standing war without any you know
what the army chief for us yeah for what
reason first of the French of a long
time commitment in there and what you
want to do is support the French and so
that we're working around the French you
know and secondly I don't wanna get into
too much detail because of suffice to
say that we've put a lot of on we've now
beefed up our forces in the Sudan and
we're gonna use that as a staging area
well the fellow in Sudan the Mary's got
his own problems he's got a north-south
problem just like they have in China
there's tremendous polarization inside
his own country are you worried about
Qaddafi yeah I don't think Gaddafi's
quite the madman everybody else does I
think that's much too simple-minded I
think Gaddafi's very shrewd much more
popular than people want to believe
particularly in northern Africa San
Antonio you're always sy Hersh good
morning and I got a found some different
things I want to talk about but just a
really simplified since we've talked
about good bad and different
I'd like to ask both of you to comment
on this do you think they'll ever be
another Teddy Roosevelt do you think
we'll ever have another president that
will be strong and won't back down
whether it be South Africa or Central
America or whatever the the danger
whether it be communism or whatever that
we're gonna because we were a country
that was built on pride and power but it
seems like our country especially since
the bomb was dropped it's like we've
diminished in our Authority we've
diminished and our integrity we've
diminished in every area and it's like I
think people are tired of hearing the
rhetoric sure we got all the ships and
everything right now in Central America
I believe in Reagan but then he's on
he's scrutinized by the press and
everybody I'm sure now he don't know
what he's gonna do okay
thanks it's a broad question but the
gentleman's suggestion that Teddy
Roosevelt was a the idea that you know
we're gonna go you know I'll tell you
how profoundly I disagree with you sir
it seems to me that we're in better
shape than we the fact that we have so
many doubts about our overseas
adventures to me as a plus because if
you somehow think that we can get you
know if you think we came out of Vietnam
with anything in terms of a heightened
self respect I don't think you did I
think we started something we couldn't
finish and the fact is that in this
world right now with everybody
maybe major power the access to nuclear
weapons you know we don't have the
ultimate terror we did it's a different
world and we have to behave differently
and we can't send our troops in the
Nicaragua like we did in the 20s and 30s
if remember it was a FDR pulled out the
Marines out of Nicaragua in 33 when he
became president I don't think we can do
it anymore I think we're gonna have to
learn that there are a lot of things in
the world that we're not going to like
and we're gonna have to live with and I
think one way to to get rid of some of
that energy is maybe to devote more time
and more attention to improving
conditions for all of us inside this
country which is a wonderful country we
live in the best country in the
I still think for all your talk about
the diminished United States those
people leaving Vietnam on boats you know
where do they want to go they're all you
know paddling you know their dream is to
get to where you know the Louisiana or
Florida I don't see anybody heading from
Moscow it seems to me we have a great
country with a great tradition and I
think we lose nothing by deciding that
we can't be the policemen of the world
and that there are other people with
other aspirations and we don't have to
put our nose in everywhere we don't have
to put our nose in chant we can try and
restrain Qaddafi we can put every
pressure we want but we simply can't be
responsible for everything and we don't
have to see everything in terms of the
Russians are doing one thing so we have
to do the other thing that is just
lunacy price of power Kissinger and the
Nixon White House is the book and the
author is with us for the next 10
minutes sy Hersh let's go back to
Manhattan good morning good are you good
good name with an IRA why I've been
watching you and the rest of step
congratulations like everybody else I
think you're probably one of the most
excellent programs on TV almost non
biased and fair handed programs I
watched McNeil Lerner last night on
television a very very interesting
program they were interviewing three of
President Reagan's advisors to all south
abroad including the president of
Project Hope during the interview the
fact came out that he he asked if we
were getting a fair press here the head
of Project Hope stated that the press in
this country is very biased liberal
biased they said as far as he could see
and he's been over there in El Salvador
in El Salvador and South America for 25
years now as doing childhood charitable
works are very good words he says there
certainly is a communist threat there
certainly is a danger and the reasons
the people are not aware of it is
because of the biased reporting by the
liberal press who has distorted the
facts and so on
people really don't know what's going on
Connor do you think the press is biased
I think that the press is not only
biased I believe that they spiked
stories that would shown for instance a
conservative thinking in a good right I
think that they constantly pick up on
store i I think they serve communism I
think that the liberal press I don't say
that they are communist but I think they
serve the cause of communism this
gentleman from Project Hope and one of
the other advisers said that what the
journalist seemed to do here the ones
that were brainwashed into liberal
schools of journalism what they do here
is they simply listen to what the left
in El Salvador has to say and then they
report it they don't talk about for
instance the death squads of the left
they don't talk about what the
Communists Castro and Russia's purpose
really is over there I think we've been
fooled for twenty years I think we lost
the Vietnam War because of gentlemen
like mr. Hersh and Bella Abzug and Jane
Fonda and they got all the glory and
they were put on the front page at at
times and I think we lost the propaganda
war in Vietnam let me ask you a question
man erupted let me ask you a question
Ronald Reagan's administration last week
I think the week before last just made a
big wheat sale to the Soviet Union the
alright a multi-million dollar we'd sale
what's he doing okay I'll tell you what
he's doing you see this was another one
that was blown out of proportion by the
liberal press mr. Reagan sat down and
realized in a very practical practical
way that the embargo of lead simply did
not work that Russia simply went to
other countries and applied the week
that they needed and the only real good
that the wheat embargo did it just heard
the farm is here and it just it was bad
for this country so we made a policy
decision to sell wheat to Russians that
doesn't mean he's feeding the Russian
army or anything nonsense that the press
but he made a practical smart decision
okay hold on hold it right away again
could save this country from I think
that the left for 20
this country has been putting a wedge
between the American people confusing
the American people and I as far as I'm
concerned I think they champion
communism okay but but but the
contradiction is just so clear I mean
well no I'm just asking you if they're
really our enemies why do you sell wheat
to them well because it's practical for
us to do so because it's an our best
interest to sell weak to them because
there's weak sitting there going bad and
as farmers were they're having a very
difficult time making ends meet and it
was just a smart move for us to sell
wheat to them does it we did not sell
wheat to them we would not bring Russia
to its knees because we didn't sell
wheat they go to France they go to other
countries as they have been doing and
they get weak anyway why do you think so
many other countries deal with Russia if
they're if there's a Russian that
there's a communist threat don't they
understand the communist threat I don't
think that most of the world understands
the communist threat and the reason I
don't think they understand the
communist threat is because of the
biased reporting in journalism in most
of the other countries including England
France and so on and so forth it's also
very interesting of course that all of
these countries a lot of these countries
that went socialist are stepping away
from now realizing that socialism is a
failed philosophy does not work as
liberalism is fails in this country and
I think that a lot of the people if they
had the facts if they if the press would
stop reporting accurately what's really
going on and I'll Salvador was really
going on in Nicaragua that the people
would be behind Reagan 100% okay let me
ask you something excuse me Brian let me
let me interrupt a second you know in
Europe most of the European countries
are more afraid of us and they are of
the Soviet Union okay okay thanks let me
approach in a different way because this
is not an unusual calling you've heard
it before from the conservative side if
you were a conservative what would you
think of the press
I think the press are terribly
predictable and I think I think Reagan's
getting a reasonably good press I think
the White House can complain bitterly
about Latin America but by and large
Reagan's got a very good press reporters
like me as good report I think the
notion that the press is in you know the
press basically eats anything it's his
own I mean as George McGovern he was
chewed up worse by the press than
anybody for all the biases in the press
and there's they're very easily capped
at made captive that's what my book
basically is about in another level -
it's about the manipulation of the press
and I just think the problem you have is
that it's awfully hard to explain to
somebody or try to argue it somebody who
says every problem is the problem of the
liberal press nothing's gonna make the
fact that it seems to me that the
Soviets have not a great investment in
Central America go away and that's
simply a fact that sits there and if the
White House had some evidence to the
contrary we would all know it the fact
is they don't
the fact is it's been a shell game for
three years and it's getting
increasingly impaired what scares me
about Central America is that Reagan's
model is the fact of the the Falklands
War and miss Thatcher's victory mrs.
Thatcher's victory and in the Falklands
and I think that I think what you're
seeing now in the next six months is
going to be the direct politicization of
the Central American War it's going to
become an adjunct to re-election which
scares the hell out of me last call for
sy Hersh on this interesting morning
Palmdale California good morning the
comments leader in Chile that I don't
think that he realizes the communist
threat and I just want an amazing
combination in effect in the world they
determined they said themselves to take
over the world and they've almost done
that they've been filled into every
government in the world so far and taken
over many and news media Wrestling is
that this first change of your parasitic
instead of getting behind our president
like they said
so could wipe up the Communists in a
hurry now there's a new line they're
getting out about the prison at first he
was a good guy he was only a good guy a
real good guy and a good actor but he
was really don't good another got a new
life things been repeated over and over
and especially by Sam Donaldson on this
man that Reagan isn't too bright okay
thank you and we have about 30 seconds
well the only point I can say is I I i
think the communists are terrified of us
I mean the Soviet Union and I think as
for a nd I think the point I'm making
about the end they was he was elected by
the people it was a democratic election
in Chile and I don't think there's much
we can do when people vote the way they
want to vote I don't think that's our
business and I think we can coexist with
the Soviet Union I don't think there's
any real problem in that I don't think
the Soviet you know they're not coming
to California tomorrow but you know you
look I'll never convince you and you'll
never convince me but we both have a
right to say what we want and I welcome
I absolutely grant you your right
because sy Hersh is controversial and
wanted you to have a chance to talk in
depth with him we stayed away from the
newspapers this morning but tomorrow
get your newspapers out and we want to
go to the headlines this is the book the
price of power Kissinger in the Nixon
White House also mr. Hirsh writes for
this magazine the Atlantic and this
particular issue the pardon Nixon Ford
Haig and the transfer of power and our
shows time's up and we hope that you'll
come back sometime and continue this
discussion buddy but that I'm bout sy
Hersh have a nice day
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]